okay well thank you all for coming today
and thank you to sierra for inviting me
i'm always grateful for an opportunity
to spread the word about prep
so today i'll be talking about prep or
hiv pre-exposure prophylaxis
which is emerged as a promising new
biomedical prevention strategy for
people who are at high risk of acquiring
hiv
despite its promise it's not as widely
known as it should be it's not as widely
talked about as i believe that it should
be and among those who do know of it and
do talk about it it's not universally
accepted
mixed reactions have been voiced not
only by society at large but within the
healthcare community in particular
and importantly prep is only as
promising as it is accessible
to the diversity of people who stand to
benefit from it
right now
because a prescription is required in
order to access prep healthcare
providers really function as gatekeepers
to prep
therefore if we want prep to be a
strategy that people are able to access
it's important that we identify and
address the perceived concerns and
barriers that health care providers
voice and in addition to recognizing the
barriers that healthcare providers are
aware of and have vocalized i think it's
also important to think about other
barriers
that healthcare providers may not be as
conscious of things like bias and
prejudice
so today i'll be starting out by giving
you basic background information about
prep
things like
what it is
how and what how well it works
why we need it and what some of the
community reactions are to it
i'm sure some of you are very well
informed about prep some of you have
probably never heard of it until today
so i just want to make sure we're all on
the same page in terms of basic
background
i'll then get into prescription
guidelines
from the cdc and barriers to prep
prescription that have been voiced by
healthcare providers
and lastly i'd like to extend the
conversation to stereotypes and the
potential for discrimination in the
prescription of prep
outlining reasons why prep might be
especially vulnerable to discriminatory
prescription practices
discussing why this is a particular
concern given the socio-demographic
distribution of hiv in this country
and also providing preliminary evidence
based on my research here at yale
okay so prep refers to hiv pre-exposure
prophylaxis it can be thought of as hiv
prevention pills
it's an antiretroviral medication in
fact it's the same medication that's
used to treat hiv among people who are
hiv positive
instead it's been being used
preventatively among people who are hiv
negative
well there are various dosing schedules
and forms of prep that are currently
under development and being tested
things like prep injections or dosing
on a monthly or
as needed basis as opposed to on a daily
basis
right now what we know is that the once
a day pill form has shown promise in
clinical trials
in particular tenofovir
disoproxyl fumarate this is abbreviated
as tdf also known as viriad and i will
be using the abbreviations or genera
brand names moving forward
um that medication and also tenofovir
disoproxal fume right
with enterocitabine
also known as truvada those two pills in
particular have shown promise in
clinical trials
so in july of 2012 the us fda approved
truvada for prescription as prep
for people who are at high risk of hiv
acquisition
so you may be wondering how prep
actually works
um essentially it interferes with the
ability of the hiv viral particles to
replicate once they're inside
a person's body
so this diagram here shows the process
by which hiv replication would typically
occur
so the large purple structure
the large purple structure
at the bottom it represents a cd4 cell
and then we can see here
the hiv virus which is represented by
the green circle with purple spots on it
now normally
without prep the hiv particle would bind
to the cell membrane as you can see
through numbers one through three and
once that binding occurs it fuses with
the cell membrane and the viral particle
releases material into the cd4 cell
including its genetic material
at that point if we're at step four now
at that point there are special enzymes
or a particular enzyme called
reverse transcriptase and it changes the
genetic material into a form that can
then be integrated into the host cell's
dna
so that allows
the
cell
to or the
new viral rna and new viral proteins to
form
they're then moving to the surface of
the cell and released as new viral
particles so that's the normal process
now the currently available form of prep
truvada
is what is called a reverse
transcriptase inhibitor so therefore it
works by
inhibiting the reverse transcriptase
which interferes with the viruses
ability
to
have its genetic material transformed
into a form that can be integrated into
the host cell's dna so it's a lot of
biology but i just kind of wanted to
give you
a little bit of the basics about why it
is that prep works or how it is that
prep works
so you might also be wondering how well
prep works
the evidence that we have for prep's
potential comes from double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trials
so for those of you who are unfamiliar
with this methodology
essentially participants were randomly
assigned
to
either a prep group or a placebo group
and
the term double blind means that both
the
participants and the research staff that
they interacted with the clinical staff
were unaware of the condition they were
assigned to
so
participants received either prep or a
placebo to take daily in pill form and
they were monitored on a monthly basis
over time
so over the course of the trial
some participants in both groups became
infected
and the overall efficacy of prep in a
given study was calculated by looking at
incidents of the of hiv in the placebo
group
as compared to the control group with
higher efficacy
indicating greater relative reduction in
incidence
follow-up analyses with a subset of the
treatment group looked at drug
concentration levels within the blood
so the relative incidence of
sero-conversion among those with
detectable levels of drug versus
undetectable were then used to estimate
risk reduction among people with
detectable levels which is thought to
represent people who were adherent
okay so i'm going to go through the four
trials that have shown promise the first
was the iprex trump or iprex trial so
this focused on
msm and trans women who had sex with men
so essentially people who were born
biologically male and had sex with men
they had to meet certain risk criteria
this one looked at truvada in particular
followed the patients for an average of
1.2 years
and overall according to the patient
self-report as well as pill counts and
measures of medication and dispensation
adherence was quite good when you look
at the drug concentration levels it was
less strong
overall they calculated a 40
44
efficacy and when they looked at
adjusting for blood concentration levels
they estimated the risk reduction to be
92 percent
so the next trial um which first
announced its findings in july of 2011
provided
evidence that prep has promised for
heterosexual individuals as well
so this
took place in botswana
as you can see with the map
and again it was truvada that they were
looking at and they determined a 62
efficacy overall
i won't give as many details for each
trial as i did in the original
so around the same time as the tdf2
results were announced the partners prep
study results were also announced so the
partners prep trial also looked at
heterosexual adults specifically it was
looking at couples who were
serodiscordant which means couples in
which one partner was hiv positive and
one partner was hiv negative
and here they looked at not just
truvada but also tdf alone or viriad
alone
and what they found was for truvada
there was a 75
efficacy overall
90 estimated risk reduction based on
blood detection
and when they looked at tdf alone it was
a 67 efficacy or 86 percent estimated
risk reduction
based on blood detection
and the last one that i wanted to touch
on is the bangkok tenofovir trial
this is the one
where results were released most
recently
and this was among men and women who
inject drugs
they looked only at tdf and found a 49
efficacy
and that number was increased to 70 when
they were looking at blood levels
okay so um here's a graph that
summarizes the efficacies that i just
mentioned
so along the left you can see that i've
listed the high-risk populations
that the various clinical trials have
focused on
and
they're in the order that i just
discussed them in
the light orange bars represent
tenofovir or tdf alone and the dark
orange bars represent tenofovir with
emtercitabine
or truvada
and
so you can see that the efficacy results
look promising and i think it's
important to remember that this is
overall for the sample and it's quite
higher when looking at blood detection
okay so
now that you have evidence for prep you
might be wondering why we need prep
simply put because hiv continues to
spread
over 30 years into the u.s epidemic we
still have about 50 000 people becoming
infected every year
we really don't have a silver bullet for
prevention we have a lot of great
prevention options but no perfect
solution
we know that abstinence works but we
know that abstinence isn't for everyone
in fact it's not for a lot of people
we know that condoms work if used
correctly and consistently
but a lot of people don't use condoms
consistently and correctly
you can stay in a monogamous partnership
with someone who is tested negative
and that in theory works but not
everybody chooses to be in a monogamous
partnership and not everybody's partner
chooses to be monogamous
treatment as prevention is another
method of prevention that has been kind
of an exciting development in the past
couple of years and this is when within
a partnership where one person is hiv
negative and the other is hiv positive
the hiv positive person
takes antiretroviral medication to
suppress his or her viral load and
therefore is less likely to transmit the
virus to the person who is hiv negative
so that has application to steroid
discordant couples
circumcision has also found to be
to provide partial protection for
men
in sexual encounters we know that clean
injection equipment can prevent
the transmission of hiv
among drug users and there's also post
exposure prophylaxis also known as pep
and this is essentially taking the
medication truvada
after a potential exposure and actual
exposure so if someone were to have
unprotected sex with someone who's hiv
positive and concerned that they may
then develop the virus if they go and
get medication within 72 hours the
earlier the better
but it's been found that they'd be less
likely to go on to develop hiv
and now we have prep too to add to the
arsenal
so you can see there's a variety of
options no one perfect solution
but for that reason a combination
prevention approach is advocated
i want to mention some of the potential
benefits
that prep may offer over other
prevention methods or when used in
conjunction with other prevention
methods which is currently recommended
so first it empowers the receptive
partner
and by the receptive partner i mean
either the woman during heterosexual
intercourse or the man who's is being
penetrated during penile anal
intercourse among two men
so
for example the receptive partner
doesn't have to rely on the insertive
partner the other partner to use a
condom consistently and correctly they
don't have to negotiate
and this along those lines
this is a covert method of hiv
prevention
so whereas with other methods such as
condoms
you know both partners are aware that
they're being used both partners have to
be on board with it in theory
someone can use prep and the other
person doesn't need to know about it
and this could be particularly
advantageous for people who want to use
condoms but don't want to rock the boat
in a relationship or could actually be
in physical danger if they were to
suggest using condoms in a relationship
in addition uh
this could potentially allow for
conception and protection simultaneously
and sarah discordant partners
and what i mean by that is if a man is
hiv positive and the woman is hiv
negative and they would like to conceive
you know condoms won't really allow for
that and so now
in theory
prep could enable the woman to become
pregnant
without
putting her at risk or putting her at
reduced risk for hiv
this
is
still we still need evidence to support
this or
more safety evidence but this is kind of
the potential that prep has
also it doesn't interrupt the heat of
the moment this is a common gripe with
condoms
the
taking of prep doesn't have to occur
during the sexual event you don't have
to stop in the middle of it it can be
you know earlier that day and it
wouldn't interrupt
other barriers to condom use or other
complaints about condoms can also be
avoided
by prep so it wouldn't necessarily serve
as a barrier to pleasure
or functioning or perceived intimacy and
all of these things have been reasons
that people have cited for not using
condoms
um also it could protect against sexual
and non-sexual hiv transmission
simultaneously so among people who both
inject drugs
and also engage in unprotected sex
this might offer dual protection
okay so now that i've outlined the
benefits of prep and i'll get into some
of the risks or concerns in just a
moment
but i want to talk about reactions to
prep
so you might think based on what i've
described
the prep is a miracle drug you know and
some leaders in the hiv prevention and
gay communities have spoken up in
support of it
for example act up was integral in
encouraging the new york state
department of health to release
guidelines that would support providers
prescription and that just came out a
few days ago
but i want to share some quotes that i
think will illustrate some of the
opinions
in the community
chris collins is the vice president of
the american foundation for aids
research and he said
we need new tools to fight this epidemic
prep is certainly not for everyone but
it may have a role in bringing hiv
infection rates down
nick letersky is a prep user and
advocate in seattle and he has been very
vocal about his own experience
in an effort to spread awareness about
prep
so for for example in an online article
that he authored he said before prep
became available i was taking a
calculated risk with my partner prep
didn't make me stop using condoms
instead prep provided me with the
protection that i would use consistently
rather than protection i was already
rejecting
brendan shukart is the editor at la at
large for positive frontiers which is an
hiv magazine for
gay and bisexual men and he described
his own experience as an hiv-positive
man who had fallen in love with
an hiv-negative man
and so um during the course of their
relationship he had taken his medication
rigorously he remained virally
suppressed and he and his boyfriend were
pretty good about condom use
but nonetheless one day his boyfriend
showed up with tears in his eyes and an
hiv-positive diagnosis
so brendan went on to describe feeling
toxic and guilty and very responsible
and for years after that he just avoided
any kind of a relationship with an
hiv-negative man
when he did then open the door to
relationships with hiv-negative men he
found that sexually was having
difficulty performing because of anxiety
around transmission
so in an op-ed earlier this month he
said
for many of us living with hiv that's
what the fda's approval of truvada for
use is prep means hope hope that one day
we can let our guard down be less than
perfectly vigilant and love without fear
thus if prep does become established as
safe and effective
in real world scenarios it would not
only bring benefits to the hiv negative
community
but also to the hiv positive community
so despite these positive reactions to
prep there have also been there's also
been some opposition
uh so some community members feel like
prep or more specifically the high-risk
population that it's targeted for
are a lost cause
for example dan savage who some of you
may know from the savage lovecast he's a
well-known sex advice columnist
and he said the following went
interviewed for the new york times just
in june of this past year
the guys these sensible care these
sensible health care folks are trying to
reach
by offering prep and pep are not
sensible they are self-identified idiots
who can only be saved by a vaccine
michael weinstein he's the president of
the aids health care foundation
and he's been a very vocal opponent of
prep
so the aids healthcare foundation is a
california-based global non-profit
organization and advocacy group that
provides hiv services to over 200 000
people
so following the release of the results
of the iprex trial
michael weinstein wrote an opinion piece
saying
the applause for this approach shows
just how disposable we consider the
lives of gay men gay men he felt like
the efficacy reports in clinical trials
was insufficient and he rallied against
the fda's approval of truvada as prep
so now that i've given you a taste of
some of the mixed reactions by community
members i want to get into the barriers
to prescription among health care
providers
there have been quite a few reservations
expressed among health care providers
and this has led to perceived difficulty
in accessing prep by some members of the
gay community
so in an article entitled the unexpected
struggle to make doctors allies in prep
jake sobo
said if you asked me what i thought the
biggest obstacles facing prep would be
it would not have immediately occurred
to me to add doctors to the list i would
have expected doctors to be an easy sell
the reality is precisely the opposite of
what i expected
um in a 2013 survey of 573 infectious
disease stocks throughout the u.s and
canada it was found that the majority
did in fact support prep
but only nine percent had actually
provided prep and about a third believed
that prep was irrelevant to their
practice
and this last point stood out to me
because of an experience that i had with
a good friend who lives in washington dc
and is
an hiv prevention researcher himself is
very well informed about prep and he's
in a stereo discordant relationship and
wanted to
get on prep um for the added layer of
protection he and his boyfriend use
condoms but he wanted to feel extra safe
and have this option
so he called me up one day incredibly
frustrated because he was trying to get
prep and couldn't get it despite the
fact he had health insurance when he
went to his primary care physician
the doctor was unfamiliar with prep and
referred him to an infectious disease
doctor then he called up several
different infectious disease doctors and
they all refused to give him an
appointment because he did not in fact
have an infectious disease
so he fortunately was able to get into a
clinical trial and is now on prep and
having a good experience with it
but not everybody is as fortunate as he
was to be living in a city where
clinical trials are going on
so you can see that many people may be
facing this problem where
they aren't able to get a prescription
from their doctor even if they have
the finances for even if they have
insurance
i think it's important to keep in mind
that if providers aren't willing to
prescribe prep
people may get it by other means
and you know i've heard of people going
to the emergency room claiming to have
had an exposure event getting a
prescription for pep and using it as
prep that's one example
there's also a street market for truvada
which if people are desperate and want
to be on prep they may turn to that
and if they're forced to go this route
think about how much less safe prep will
be
without the consistent monitoring
without the consistent hiv testing and
the adherence counseling and so on
okay so before i get into the uh
provider's views i want to just give you
a basic rundown on the prescription
guide prescription guidance that's been
put out by the cdc
um
so before
starting a patient on prep a doctor
should confirm that the the patient is
hiv negative confirmed that he or she is
at ongoing very high risk for acquiring
hiv infection
unfortunately the cdc
doesn't provide many examples of what
this means and as a result it's pretty
subject to interpretation
and i'll get into why that might be a
problem when i discuss my own research
so when writing a prescription no more
than a 90-day supply should be
prescribed
and the patient should should come in
for regular follow-up visits every two
to three months at which point he or she
should be tested for hiv other stis and
pregnancy
the provider should also evaluate the
patient's level of adherence offer
support around adherence and the
provider should be asking about the
patient's behavior
and assess the patient's level of risk
and if appropriate the provider should
then offer risk reduction counseling and
condoms
so now let's get into some of the
concerns that providers have expressed
and these are also the basis of
opposition among some community members
a big one that we hear again and again
is sexual risk compensation so sexual
risk compensation refers to an increase
in sexual risk taking behavior due to a
perceived decrease in susceptibility to
hiv acquisition
so the concern is if a man is prescribed
prep he will then
go and have more unprotected sex or
increase his number of partners and
essentially the prep prescription will
do more harm than good
so far there has not been substantial
evidence for risk compensation occurring
in prep
in fact several trials have reported
decreases in risk behavior across the
duration of the study
that being said our evidence comes from
clinical trials or open label extensions
thereof and therefore they're not
representative of the real world so in
other words people who are in the
clinical trials they don't know if
they're
on the placebo or on prep and especially
in the early
trials they were unaware of any efficacy
of prep so they would probably be less
likely to increase their risk behavior
because they might not have that
perceived decrease in susceptibility
so what we know so far is based on
people who have been in clinical trials
and within the clinical trials have
gotten very comprehensive hiv prevention
services
which although may be recommended for
real world
implementation as well in reality
people may not have access to that
comprehensive of a prevention package so
therefore these individuals are not
representative of real world individuals
so we don't yet know really what risk
compensation is going to look like
once prep is out there in the real world
we're still waiting on effectiveness
data
another concern is that
patients will acquire other stis so
along the same lines if they start using
prep and reduce their condom use
they may be putting themselves at risk
for stis other than hiv
um adherence is also a big concern
um
so
there's concern that people will be
inconsistent about adherence and then
you know susceptible to hiv but
in addition there's this added issue of
viral resistance
in that because the medication that's
used for prep is also the same
medication used to treat hiv there's
concern that individuals
will
acquire hiv may be sort of
inconsistently adherent acquire hiv
without knowing it and then continue to
be sort of inconsistently adherent and
in the process develop drug resistance
or
resistance to
the virus would be resistant to the
medication
there's also concern that they may be
more likely to select for um they may be
more likely to acquire drug resistance
strains although there hasn't been
evidence of this
in terms of the data so far resistance
has been extremely rare
there have been some developments of
viral resistance but i think altogether
it was about five people across all four
trials that i covered
okay
another issue that comes up is cost and
reimbursement
and
so far fingers crossed most insurance
companies and state medicaid programs
have been covering prep
and also gilead has a medication
assistance program for those people who
are low income they will provide prep
for free so
hopefully cost won't be too much
interference in
writing these prescriptions
another big one is drug toxicity and
side effects and you know doctors feel
like why would we be prescribing these
medications that could cause side
effects to perfectly healthy individuals
especially if there are other means of
prevention
i mean the argument is that there are
other medications that are prescribed to
healthy individuals for preventive
reasons that do have side effects
but beyond that
the side effects have been pretty
minimal for
truvada is prep so
there's been basically a comparable
level of serious adverse events between
placebo groups and treatment groups
within clinical trials
the primary side effect that is seen
with truvada is gi issues such as nausea
however that's seen in a minority it's
usually just for the first month or so
and dissipates so it is pretty mild
there's also been reported a one percent
reduction in bone mineral density
and there's concern about renal
complications although renal
complications haven't been
highly supported by the clinical trials
i think that concern comes more from
looking at truvada within people who are
hiv positive
okay um so safety and efficacy and lack
of real world evidence are another
concern you know right now we have the
clinical trial evidence that i presented
but right now we don't really know what
it's going to look like in the real
world and so this is a concern for
providers
they're also
unwilling to prescribe because of a lack
of personal knowledge
um
and so i think that you know it's up to
a provider to be knowledgeable about the
prevention options that are out there
but also for those of us who are in
public health i think we have a role in
educating providers about prep
in order to increase their knowledge
resources have also come up and so
this could be in a couple of different
ways so some providers feel like they
simply don't have
the
time personally to be monitoring these
patients so closely and sitting down and
having these adherence counseling or
risk counseling sessions or they
wouldn't have the the staff to do it
and also resources have been expressed
as a concern in terms of
resource allocation
so using a particular medication for
preventative versus treatment purposes
if there's a limited supply in resource
limited senate
settings
and finally
there's also concerns about needs so
some providers simply feel like there
are other alternatives good alternatives
that work
there's no need for prep
and also there's debate around risk
level
you know at what level of risk should a
person really be prescribed prep
so now i'd like to turn to some of my
recent research
so what i'll be presenting today is a
pilot study that i conducted with my
colleagues here at yale
entitled the impact of patient race on
clinical decisions related to
prescribing hiv pre-exposure prophylaxis
assumptions about sexual risk
compensation and implications for
access um so first it's important i
think just to kind of set the stage for
this work to note the social disparities
in hiv prevalence
racial and sexual minority groups
continue to be disproportionately
affected
so
black men represent less than 14 percent
of the us male population and yet they
account for 38 percent of
u.s men living with hiv
we know that black msm in particular
bear the brunt of the burden among black
men so even though black msm account for
probably
two to five percent of the black male
population they account for almost
three-quarters of all newly acquired hiv
infections
we know that establishing effective and
accessible hiv prevention strategies for
communities of high preference is a
national health priority
therefore it's important to look at prep
and the potential benefit that it might
offer to some of these minority
communities where there is a high
prevalence of hiv
so while prep is indeed an exciting new
strategy for hiv prevention
the real world effectiveness of it will
depend critically upon provider uptake
and appropriate implementation within
clinical practice
and for multiple reasons prep might be
especially vulnerable to discriminatory
prescription practices
first there's documentation of racial
disparities in patient diagnosis and
treatment
across medical conditions so this is
pervasive throughout health care and
hiv care is no exception so multiple
studies have shown that black patients
experience longer delays to receiving
antiretroviral medication when in care
this could be foretelling of race-based
differences in receipt of antiretroviral
medication for preventive purposes in
other words prep
we also know that greater reliance on
provider discretion as opposed to clear
clinical criteria increases the risk of
discrimination occurring
so research has shown that racial
discrimination is more likely in
contexts in which
behavioral norms or situational demands
are ambiguous and that this applies to
medical settings
so as mentioned previously right now um
clear eligible criteria clear
eligibility criteria are lacking um so
the cdc has put out this
guidance but it's labeled interim
guidance as they work on more
comprehensive
guidelines for providers
and so right now
you know they they say that someone
needs to be at very high risk
they offer an example or two but they
don't really give specifics
the maker of the medication itself
gilead
as well as some other sources have tried
to offer more specifics but for the most
part
who is eligible and who is not and who
qualifies is really dependent on the
provider's discretion
and we know that provider opinions about
hypothetical cases and standards are
conflicting so there has been research
that has presented providers with these
different cases and we we indeed see
that there's controversy controversy
among them
so as mentioned previously one concern
that's been repeatedly expressed as a
deterrent to prescribing prep is sexual
risk compensation
to date there's
really no substantial evidence for
sexual risk compensation with prep
there's
no evidence for racial disparities in
sexual risk compensation so
there's no reason to believe that
a black man or a black
gay or bisexual man would engage in more
sexual risk than
a white man or a white man who has sex
with men
nonetheless we know that there are these
sexual stereotypes out there of black
men and
black msm in particular as being
sexually risky and out of control
importantly there's no empirical basis
for this not just in terms of prep
research but also
you know if you look at sexual risk
taking in general in the msm community
we know that black msm
do not engage in more risk behavior than
their other race counterparts in fact in
many ways they're a bit better about
condom use
or so less risky than other racial
groups
nonetheless because we do know that
there are these stereotypes
it's possible that stereotypes could
influence clinical judgment
okay so
i have
within my program of research i have
several overarching research goals so
first based on this background i gave
you
i want to identify disparities in
clinical judgments about prep based on
patient race as well as other patient
characteristics so things like sexual
orientation and gender
the potential risk behavior whether it's
sexual or drug use
and so on
and i want to look at how these
different factors affect predictions
about sexual risk compensation among
providers as well as providers
willingness to prescribe prep
the goal of this research beyond that is
to understand the psychological
mechanisms that underlie disparities in
judgment in order to
address the disparities through provider
targeted educational interventions
so today what i'll be focusing on is the
pilot study
which addresses the first goal
the latter two goals are part of a
planned program of research that i've
mapped out over the next few years
so
in the pilot study that i'll be
presenting my colleagues and i chose to
look at medical students in particular
as healthcare providers
because they are providers in training
they in theory have many years of
service ahead of them
and
we we thought that they may be more
likely to draw on their formal medical
education as opposed to clinic
background clinical experience
so my colleagues and i approached the
study with two objectives in mind
first to examine the predictions about
sexual risk compensation for a black man
who has sex with men as opposed to a
white man who has sex with men
and um
in in particular we're gonna we wanted
to look at it in the context of
a primary care scenario where the person
was actually seeking out prep
we also wanted to test the indirect
effect of patient race on prep
prescription willingness through sexual
risk compensation so specifically we
hypothesized that
the black patient would be judged as
more likely to increase
his sexual risk taking if prescribed
prep and that this in turn would lead to
a reduced willingness to prescribe prep
to the patient
okay so we tested these objectives using
an online survey in which participants
were presented with a vignette
describing
a patient who is seeking prep
in a primary care scenario and then they
were asked to make clinical decisions
about that patient
so patient race was systematically
manipulated such that participants were
randomized to one of two conditions
describing either a black patient or a
white patient
asking for prep in this medical scenario
so an initial and follow-up email
request for participation in an
anonymous online survey about attitudes
towards prescribing prep was distributed
to the yale medical student listserv
our final sample was comprised of 102
medical students
so the survey itself consisted of four
parts
um first participants were provided with
background information about truvada
including its purpose uh partial
efficacy according to the three clinical
trials that had taken place up until
then and its approval by the fda
second they were presented with quotes
representing popular arguments for and
against the prescription of prep
then the clinical vignette itself was
displayed which i'll show you in just a
moment
and finally participants were asked to
make a series of clinical judgments
pertaining to the vignette and to
respond to other survey items
so here's the vignette that the
participants were shown i've highlighted
key purpose or key pieces of information
just for the purpose of this talk
so the vignette read as follows mr j is
a 31 year old
black man who's hiv negative he presents
to you his primary care physician
stating that he wants to take the
medication to help prevent himself from
getting hiv
he has insurance that would cover the
prescription
mr j currently has one male sex partner
who has been diagnosed as hiv positive
and with whom he is monogamous
during previous appointments you've
discussed you've discussed hiv risk with
him and encouraged him to use condoms
however he does not always use them
resulting in repeated episodes of
unprotected sex with his partner
hiv antibody and rna lab tests confirmed
that mr j is hiv negative he's never had
any stds he has no physical complaints
he's never had surgery or been
hospitalized his medical history is
otherwise unremarkable
mr j does not use alcohol tobacco or
other drugs he has no known drug
allergies and is not currently taking
any medication
so after participants were shown that
vignette they were asked a series of
questions
they were asked about predicted sexual
risk compensation so specifically we
asked how likely would this patient be
to have more unprotected sex if he
started taking truvada as prep
we asked about prep prescription
willingness specifically asking would
you prescribe truvada as prep to this
patient
and we also asked about other clinical
judgments things like predicted
adherence
risk of the patient's risk of hiv
infection if they were not to prescribe
prep
the risk reduction that they associated
with prep
we asked about racial bias as well
which we conceptualized as perceived
importance of the patient's request as
well as general feelings towards black
patients versus white patients
and finally we asked about background
characteristics including both
sociodemographics as well as medical
training characteristics
so univariate analyses of covariance
controlling for participant race were
used to compare clinical judgments
between patient race conditions
we used hierarchical linear regression
in order to
look at predictors of prescription
willingness
and finally we tested for the indirect
effect that i showed you in the diagram
earlier using bootstrapping
moving on to the results
in terms of sample characteristics
participants were evenly split by gender
the two largest racial groups
represented were white and asian there
were very few latinos blacks or people
of other races
the majority of participants identified
as heterosexual
and students from all years of medical
school were represented
notably none of these characteristics
differed significantly across conditions
so our first goal was to
examine the effect of patient race on
predictions about sexual risk
compensation
so this table here displays means
comparisons between conditions in terms
of clinical judgments of the black
patient which is condition one
versus clinical judgments of the white
patient which is condition two
as you can see along the left column
these are the different different
clinical judgments that were examined
and by looking at the p values you can
see that the one that emerged as
significantly different was patient
sexual risk compensation
so you can see that the black patient
was judged as more likely to engage in
sexual risk compensation than the white
patient next we sought to examine the
effect of predicted sexual risk
compensation on willingness to prescribe
prep
controlling for patient race
uh so this table shows results from our
our hierarchical linear regression
the independent variables are listed in
the left column
and the lines represent the
three different sets of variables
that were
entered i want to draw your attention to
the variable at the bottom which is
predicted patient sexual risk
compensation which was added by itself
in the third and final step
i'll blow this up for you
so you can see that predicted patient
sexual risk compensation
was highly significantly related to
prescription willingness
overall our model accounted for 32
percent of the variance in willingness
to prescribe prep
and the addition of that one variable to
the model accounted for an additional 11
percent of the variance
so finally we sought to test the entire
model testing the indirect effect of
patient race on prep prescription
willingness through predicted sexual
risk compensation
we used bootstrapping to calculate a
bias corrected and accelerated 95
confidence interval of the indirect
effect
and as can be seen a significant
indirect effect emerged
as indicated by a confidence interval
that did not straddle zero
so turning to the model you can see the
unstandardized coefficients and standard
errors
for all of the paths
and
to summarize these
results indicated that the black patient
was judged as more likely to engage in
sexual risk compensation which in turn
was related to reduced prescription
willingness
so in summary the black patient was
judged as more likely to engage in
sexual risk compensation than the white
patient
and keep in mind in this particular
scenario the hypothetical patient was
kind of a straight edge you know he was
kind of a goody two shoes he didn't
drink he didn't smoke or do drugs and
importantly he was monogamous
some might say he was the ideal
candidate for prep and yet despite the
fact that he did not fit the black male
stereotype of being sexually out of
control or hypersexual by description we
still found this difference
we also found that predicted patient
sexual risk compensation was strongly
associated associated with prep
prescription willingness
over and above sociodemographic and
medical training characteristics racial
bias and other forms of clinical
judgment
patient race was indirectly related to
prescription willingness such that the
black patient
was judged as more likely to engage in
sexual risk and this was linked to
reduced willingness to prescribe
okay so in terms of future research some
of which i alluded to and sharing my
research goals
i think it's important to look at other
healthcare provider samples i think it's
very interesting
to focus on the medical student
community but we also want to know what
biases exist among people who are
actively prescribing
and actively practicing presently
also we want to look beyond just
we want to look in other clinical
settings if ideally prep is going to be
implemented across a broad spectrum of
clinical settings we want to find out
what biases and discriminatory practices
might occur in those settings and to
look
throughout
throughout the country
i'm also interested in looking at
moderators
things like provider characteristics in
particular provider race
it's been shown previously that
provider race and the concordance
between provider race and patient race
is related to
decisions around hiv treatment so i
think it's interesting to look at that
in the future unfortunately we just
didn't have the numbers to look at it
with this sample
also i want to look at other patient
characteristics including gender and
sexual orientation
and risk behavior
i also want to explore psychological
mechanisms so looking at the implicit
and or explicit biases and prejudice
they might be underlying these clinical
decisions
and finally it's important to look at
this in real world prescription behavior
right now this is just within the
context of a clinical vignette we want
to see if this is actually happening as
prep is rolled out
this research has implications for
future intervention as well first it
speaks to
the potential or the need to increase
awareness about prep among providers and
to prevent stereotypes from adversely
affecting clinical judgment
there are several different
approaches to
doing this that have been put forward in
the field of social cognitive psychology
including things like emphasizing
individuation or focusing on individual
characteristics as opposed to social
categorization or group membership
also building a sense of partnership
between the patient and the provider and
informing providers about their own
vulnerability to stereotyping and
discrimination
so prep is a promising prevention
strategy hopefully i've convinced you of
that
i think it has great potential to impact
the hiv epidemic
but whether you're on board with it or
not at this point i think we can all
agree that if it is going to be
prescribed it should be prescribed
fairly and people across the social
spectrum should have equal access to it
therefore stereotypes and biases should
not be allowed to become bases for
denying access
black msm which is the group that i
focused on in my research they comprise
one of many different socially
marginalized groups who stand to benefit
from prep
other social groups who are considered
to be at heightened risk based on
their socio-demographic characteristics
or their behavioral practices so groups
like transgender individuals or sex
workers they also might confront
healthcare bias that interferes with
access to prep so it's important to
consider other groups as well
so far in hearing about
kind of barriers to equitable access
most of what i've heard about is things
like cost and resource allocation but we
really need to consider
other factors as well not just
structural
i think it's essential that we start
having honest conversations about race
and how race and how stereotypes play
into clinical decision making
in presenting this work my
purpose is not to or my intention is not
to name call or point fingers at
healthcare providers most are very well
intentioned who are just individuals who
are just trying to maximize the health
of their patients
however like it or not healthcare
providers
and everyone else in this room are
members of a society where stereotypes
still exist and stereotypes influence
behavior and sometimes unconsciously
therefore we can't ignore the potential
influence of stereotypes on treatment in
the health care system and related to
prep specifically
what i also want to drive home is that
timing is critical for increasing
awareness about stereotypes and their
potential impact on prep related
clinical judgments
right now is when
prep is being introduced to healthcare
settings across the country right now is
when the cdc is putting together these
more comprehensive guidelines so i think
it could be valuable to integrate some
of this material
into these introductions and into these
guidelines
finally i want to acknowledge my
co-authors some of whom are in the room
as well as
the yale university interdisciplinary
hiv prevention training program the t32
program of which i'm a part
sierra
dr jamie meyer who's in the audience and
helped us to refine our clinical
vignette dr nancy ingoth who helped with
recruitment and the new haven restaurant
owners who
donated gift certificates to serve as
participant incentives
finally i want to thank the medical
student participants
who made this research happen
i also want to put in a quick plug
for those of you who are interested in
discussion and debate and or research on
the topic of prep
dr margaret weeks is uh forming a
prep interest group
and
you are welcome to contact her at this
address or if you want to reach out to
me i will put you in touch with her